the race to find a kovid 19 vaccine
has been one of the greatest challenges
in the history of the pharmaceutical
industry
among dozens of contenders the german
biotechnology firm bioentec
became the first company in the eu to
receive authorization for a vaccine
bioentech normally develops treatments
for cancer patients and was a recipient
of financial support from the eu
investment programs
now known as invest eu when the pandemic
began
it changed course teaming up with
pharmaceutical company pfizer
to develop a vaccine biotech
existing apartment is important
meps also pushed for strategic
investments in medical supplies
and pharmaceutical manufacturing all
while keeping the economic impact of the
pandemic in mind
[Music]
invest eu provides guarantees for
projects which are in line with eu
priorities
such as building a sustainable and
digital economy
the program aims to mobilize 400 billion
euros in additional investment
across the eu which will be injected
right back into smes
climate goals and research
you